[Music]
in bad tenants news Oh [ __ ] hey Pat
submitted by hello muddah people hello
murder hello father
businesses claim a church's worst tenant
than a strip club I charge the worst
tenant yes I always forget that churches
especially like the newer modern
especially like the Korean churches that
aren't in a like religious Cathedral
looking building they're just like an
office space I always forget that
someone still owns that space like a
businessman or a landlord I just think
of as a place of worship so it's
immediately excluded for my normal
memory but then when I Drive by and
sometimes I see like a really big
business based on my damn some
[ __ ] donut donated this thing to
them for free why don't they get out to
JK we can make more good out of it make
a religion they donated it don't they
pay rent
I think they pay rent yeah that's why
they ask for money but then there's some
stirred nonprofit you know expensive
some of those places like a big-ass
built like some of the shows that we did
it's like a 20,000 30,000 square-foot
Church ya know in a business park yeah
they just build too so like the old
church that I used to go to a Sacramento
they're like one of the biggest Korean
churches now so back in the day it used
to be this busted-up field in this crack
court and then we used to play
basketball on they actually have a
full-on [ __ ] indoor gym now just from
like the church growing already that's
pretty [ __ ] dope dude some of these
kids don't understand sarcasm too
because when I said that on the podcast
this kid was like hey man all the church
people worked hard but don't be mad at
us I'm like it's a joke you [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] stupid idiot [ __ ] goad I did and
then go see Jesus and ask him why you
were [ __ ] dumbass
also there's tithing so is that I think
it's like was it ten or ten percent of
the income so you're a monthly income
whatever tithing
so in I guess it's like it's in the
Bible where they're telling you to put
10% and give it to God what I'm offering
though tithing is comprising is more
like a
it's like an expected temperature mount
10% of your income that is because I
heard about the 10% yeah I just never
had so imagine if all of your adult
members that are working is paying 10%
of their income yeah
so every time when the offering plate
passes and then they have their little
thing there'd like tithing - yeah I
would tie it only a dollar simply
because I was poor I made $100 then if I
made $100 I would give them great you
made $10 yeah $10 and I would give them
one it was $100 I would still give them
$1.00 yeah so this church here is but a
former strip club and they put their
sign Balma before my strip club but it's
right next to a nude theater so it's
still raunchy they're just uh so it goes
like Church new theater yeah [ __ ]
pastor comes down so they all kept the
same cage the sooner those are coming
out the way good luck in the comment
glitter off your face okay I guess so
right next door it's um I believe it's a
printing business so then it's like
printing business
former strip club turns Church and then
a new theater isn't Florida this isn't
San Diego oh oh [ __ ]
and so they're saying that ever since
the Rock Church bought that property the
rock no Rock Church that's the name of
it I know the rock I'm saying that the
rock is huge like is it so the rock is
that you man like church franchise or
Church a huge Church like the one I used
to go to with my brother was in San
Diego and the guy yeah the rock the rock
is dope is one of my probably one of the
best churches I went to well they hate
the church though they're like it's the
worst tenant because they leave it all
like [ __ ] up and then there's homeless
people there and they're doing drugs all
the time and right in front of it and
just like they suck as being tenants
because I keep saying that they're gonna
hate clean it up and do things to the
actual building but the buildings like
deteriorating and they're not even using
in they bought it for 2.3 million
dollars why don't they use the tithing
yeah also they're not tenants their
owners well they're calling them tenants
because they own it I don't know but
you're right it shouldn't what I was
thinking like well I was thinking like a
tenant like someone who's like leasing
it from from another landowner and then
the landlord's like these are the worst
tenant sighs yeah I guess they're just
talking about the fact that they are in
the same business that makes sense you
pay an HOA even though you own the condo
yeah so once again clean up but all the
businesses around they're just saying
like man they just be suck like every
time we've walked by there and it's
affecting the surrounding businesses
because of the maybe it's a different
one cuz they all the strip clubs are
like hey be respectable Christians what
the [ __ ] it is the thing what you're
talking about oh really that's so
interesting because that church I went
to they there were so many volunteers
they would clean up everything and it
was just spic-and-span every time is it
that logo huh Mountain I can't remember
I used to go there long ago if you went
to church of rock maybe maybe because a
strip club is open like every day and
they have security in a strip club they
bought it before so their previous
tenant which was a strip club had
security they were open every day it was
operating business we'll just try oh so
no so so then they were they were
maintaining it versus a church it's once
a week typically right well at some
times but it's not like as active with
the security on you know so these people
trashing a lot of gone it doesn't seem
like so this is their statement over the
past several months we have been
reviewing our options for the use of the
property formerly known as the body shop
we understand this area is in the mid
wave district they didn't even move in
yet has had homeless encampment issues
over the past several years even before
we took possession of the property our
facilities staff goes a couple times a
week to check on the property and to see
how we can help those individuals camped
outside
Rock Church continues to help the
homeless through our various outreach
ministries as we are made aware of each
individual case in addition to providing
help to those in need we are also in
closing the front door entryway with
fencing where so much activity takes
place we have also requested the San
Diego Police Department to increase
their patrols of the area that's what
they said maybe they're buying out all
these like sinful businesses yeah ah get
out of here get out of key yeah that's
maybe what they're doing so they're not
in there yet
so they have to they just bought the
spot and they're just sitting there yeah
that's funny
yeah but then they're saying that a lot
of the people like the homeless people
they'll have food feces oh [ __ ] where
you eat I know and they're saying that
like on the walls on our vehicles and
the nave and this [ __ ] on the course
yeah
and they even tagged up like the
neighboring businesses they're graffiti
artists to wait till they're blaming
that on the church so would he be mad at
the church because it seems like the
church just doesn't take care of that
property so because of that reason
that's why all these homeless people are
coming and camping squatting and stuff
like that if I was a homeless man and
the minute I feel like I need a poop I
would be so excited cuz it's almost like
yes the brown crayons coming out and I
would immediately start walking up to
every Y to spread my butt cheek and as I
was pushing the gray yarn out I would
just start drawing stuff with your back
gonna do just seen there your ass is too
big really yeah I don't think you would
ever touch the wall
snap off before it does that and then
pick it up yeah it's like what do you
have to very hydrated to it's like gonna
be hard McKenna in that leg comes out
but it's not long enough so it keeps
going back it
you got to get good at pulling that
soft-serve that's such a weird situation
so they just saw what their solution is
that they're gonna fence it off which
yeah that makes sense I feel like the
other business can also be like yo shoo
shoo like get out of here I guess since
it's not there I want a religion so bad
can you imagine a company that you don't
even get taxed on
that's what Scientology did no that's so
genius yeah they're like it's the alien
religion what they built it off of
sci-fi books yeah that's crazy and then
they're like we're and then you see the
video of them celebrating that they got
like approved to be taxed for you or
whatever no yeah a celebration you know
that going clear oh yeah I didn't watch
that documentary
I heard though it's pretty dope it's
about like people that left Scientology
and like the crazy [ __ ] that that
happens in it and like some people made
it through all the way like so you're
supposed to make it all the way through
this program and it costs tons of money
they basically take all your money yeah
and and if you try to leave the church
you like get hounded and stalked and all
this stuff and if you try to like
befriend Remini one yeah that wasn't
part of it yeah yeah that's kind of that
came after going clear but but yeah some
people actually went through the entire
program and it nothing happens like you
they think like oh my god they're
something Crazy's gonna happen and they
crossed the bridge or whatever and then
it's just like they get access to like
this new book that that talks about
going into space or whatever it's just a
book it's like a sci-fi sucks too
because by that 10 they've already spent
millions of dollars and nothing and then
I'm gonna teach you a magic trick at the
very end you pay millions of dollars
they're like are this is what we do this
religions fake it's like to do that law
you know yeah and they have a lot of
tape of you saying your deepest
confessions and like all of your regrets
and everything like there's so many
therapy sessions and stuff and they do
like hypnosis all kinds of stuff I
wonder if you could just go in there and
just if you're just a ball in person and
you could just fake it throughout the
whole thing just start saying crazy [ __ ]
probably maybe see
your money I wonder if you want much not
harmful like to to each other but we
we're doing it because we want to create
something new but when you diet corrupt
people are gonna take over that's true
never mind never thought about it that
way I just want to give a purpose for
people to live yeah so did Jesus yeah
but where he go once he goes all this
corrupt like some of those own places
are still good but then you know that's
true there's always corruption somewhere
there's always a pimp out there trying
to exploit the game yeah [ __ ] out
stuff in writing on walls hey that's
very innocent
[Music]